este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
blink is seguro que a ti al igual que a
mí muchas veces tienes la sensación de
que no te da la vida para ponerte a leer
tantos libros como te gustaría o como
solía hacer incluso ahora que estamos en
casa y que pensamos que íbamos a tener
todo el tiempo del mundo luego en el día
a día lo cierto es que las horas se nos
van así o me equivoco bueno pues que me
venía y si te dijese que existen una
aplicación que en 15 minutos os resumen
miles y miles de libros de no ficción en
inglés libros de todo tipo y ojo no solo
en texto sino también en formato audio
que oye por un lado nunca viene mal
hacer oído y por otro pues no sé a veces
estás en casa y el audio te resulta
mucho más cómodo pues bien el caso es
que esta aplicación existe y tiene un
nombre bling ist mira una de las cosas
que más nos habéis pedir siempre en
visual político es que os recomendamos
libros pues en bien kiss encontraréis
muchos de los que siempre decimos
apuesta aseguradas cómo freakonomics o
porque fracasan los países y luego te
están también tal eppinger en fin que no
os defraudará
incluso si os gusta el mundo de la
inversión vais a encontrar muchos libros
obligatorios como por ejemplo el
inversor inteligente pues bien presta
atención los primeros 100 de vosotros
que vayáis a bling puntocom
tendréis acceso ilimitado por una semana
para probarlo
totalmente gratis si nos convence podéis
cancelar los sin problemas durante esos
siete días y ojo en caso de que os guste
disfrutaréis también de un 25 por ciento
de descuento para un full member sí
gracias a bien que es por ofrecer esta
oportunidad a la comunidad de visual
política y por apoyar nuestro proyecto y
sin más arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
al final hubo acuerdo
aparentemente el pulso desatado entre
saudíes y rusos ha llegado a su fin
amigos tal y como os contamos aquí en
visual político en la pasada cumbre del
día 6 de marzo de la conocida como peck
plus rusia se negó a recortar su
producción como respuesta a la crisis el
coronavirus en esas circunstancias la
réplica del ave saudí no se hizo esperar
literalmente la potencia árabe anunció
públicamente que inundaría el mercado de
crudo hasta llevar al límite su
capacidad y emiratos árabes su gran
socio político haria exactamente lo
mismo esto provocó todo un terremoto en
el mercado de la energía el precio del
petróleo llegó a caer más de un 60%
desde comienzos de año y por ejemplo el
precio del barril de brent se acercó a
los 20 dólares un precio no visto en
mucho pero que mucho tiempo
[Música]
evidentemente tal y como os podéis
imaginar que el precio del petróleo se
hunda tiene consecuencias positivas o
negativas en función de qué país estemos
hablando por ejemplo si hablamos de
consumidores como alemania japón o
francia países que tienen que importar
prácticamente todo el crudo que consumen
el efecto es positivo pero sí en cambio
hablamos de rusia arabia saudita o
incluso eeuu entonces entonces las
consecuencias pueden ser catastróficas
un momento eeuu si lo habéis escuchado
bien
desde que hace algo más de 10 años se
puso en marcha la conocida como
revolución del fracking la producción
petrolera de los eeuu no ha parado de
crecer
y el caso amigos es que las pérdidas
potenciales de decenas y decenas cientos
de miles de millones de dólares para
rusia y los países árabes junto a las
fuertes presiones de washington que ojo
incluso amenazó con romper su relación
estratégica con riad e imponer aranceles
a la importación del petróleo árabe
hicieron que el pasado 12 de abril de
2020 los miembros de la opep plus se
volviera a sentar a negociar
y en esta ocasión si hubo acuerdo
los países petroleros que forman parte
de lo que se conoce como la opep plus
recordarán su producción en 97 millones
de barriles diarios durante los meses de
mayo junio luego hasta final de 2020 el
recorte será de 8 millones y finalmente
entre enero del 2021 y abril del 2022
el ajuste sumará a 6 millones de
barriles diarios
ahora bien un momento porque puede que
este acuerdo no sea suficiente no al
menos a corto plazo
veréis la caída de la demanda provocada
por las medidas de confinamiento y el
cierre de empresas declaradas para
luchar contra la propagación del
coronavirus puede ser mucho mayor que la
oferta algunos expertos hablan de una
caída en el consumo de unos 20 millones
de barriles al día
eso explica por ejemplo que las
previsiones de goldman sachs apunten a
una nueva caída del precio del petróleo
durante los próximos meses de tal forma
que las inversiones que ya se han parado
difícilmente volverán a ponerse en
marcha para que os hagáis una idea
hablamos de una caída en las inversiones
globales en exploración y producción de
crudo durante el 2020 de más de 100 mil
millones de dólares según la consultora
randstad energy
y claro todo esto es algo que puede
tener unas consecuencias gigantescas
sobre muchas economías y que incluso
puede llegar a poner contra las cuerdas
a la propia campaña para la reelección
de donald trump si si lo habéis
escuchado bien
el colapso los mercados del petróleo
puede hacer mucho daño en algunos de los
estados más prósperos de los eeuu y
estados como por ejemplo tejas
amigos amigas de visual política el
estado de texas durante las últimas
décadas una de las locomotoras de la
economía norteamericana puede estar a
punto de enfrentarse a una tormenta de
consecuencias impredecibles a la
sacudida de dos grandes crisis la crisis
de coronavirus y el colapso del mercado
del petróleo
en este vídeo os vamos a contar todos
los detalles sobre lo que está
ocurriendo en el estado de la estrella
solitaria pero antes antes tenemos que
hablar de los 'bonos basura' el boom del
oro negro y los 'bonos basura'
seguro que todos habéis escuchado hablar
de ellos pero os hago una pregunta
sabéis exactamente qué son los 'bonos
basura'
[Música]
pues bien digamos que así es como se
conocen los títulos de deuda que tienen
un alto riesgo de impago y que en
contraprestación tienen que pagar tipos
de intereses más altos es decir vamos a
ver para qué un inversor compre deuda
con muchas probabilidades de impago
lógicamente la rentabilidad que le va a
dar esa deuda tiene que compensar ese
riesgo
hablamos de títulos de deuda que
generalmente son emitidos por empresas
como conocidas empresas nuevas o
compañías que tienen una situación
financiera complicada eso es lo que se
conoce como bonos basura deuda con mucho
más riesgo
pero puede que algunos os estáis
preguntando pero enrique porque demonios
nos hablas de estas cosas en un vídeo
sobre texas pues amigos porque estos
bonos basura han sido ni más ni menos
que los grandes propulsores del despegue
petrolero de los eeuu
veréis me explico cuando en el 2008 el
precio del petróleo estaba literalmente
por las nubes llegó a superar los 150
dólares por barril una nueva tecnología
comenzó a florecer o mejor dicho los
nuevos desarrollos hicieron que una
tecnología que ya se conocía y que era
carísima de utilizar derrepente fuese
rentable estoy hablando del fracking
en ese momento en los eeuu las compañías
de fracking comenzaron a surgir como
setas en gran medida gracias al dinero
fresco con el que durante los siguientes
años wall street' comenzó a inundar este
sector no importaba si se trataba de
empresas nuevas pequeñas sin patrimonio
o con modelos de negocio más
cuestionables que las tesis doctorales
de muchos políticos da igual el
potencial de beneficios casi ilimitados
y la política de tipos por los suelos de
la reserva federal hicieron que wall
street' inyectar a decenas y decenas de
miles de millones que hicieron crecer
este sector como la espuma durante diez
de los últimos 11 años las compañías
energéticas han sido los mayores
deudores de 'bonos basura'
[Música]
de hecho desde el 2016 cuando los
precios de petróleo comenzaron a bajar
más de 200 productores norteamericanos
se han declarado en quiebra con más de
120 mil millones de dólares en deudas
y ahora ahora el nuevo hundimiento del
precio del petróleo ha vuelto a poner a
decenas y decenas de compañías contra
las cuerdas simple y llanamente porque
este precio del petróleo sus operaciones
no son rentables y además tienen un
montón de deuda acumulada
[Música]
según las estimaciones de la agencia de
calificación moody's las compañías
norteamericanas de exploración y
producción de petróleo junto a las
empresas que controlan los oleoductos en
los eeuu se enfrentan a más de 200 mil
millones de deuda que van a vencer
durante los próximos 4 años es decir más
de 200 mil millones que van a tener que
devolver mientras los precios del
petróleo están por los suelos y 'wall
street' ya no está dispuesto a
refinanciar a cualquier precio
es decir en otras palabras que muchas de
estas empresas pues van a quebrar y
sabéis dónde se localizan la mitad de
todas estas compañías en riesgo pues sí
exactamente en el estado de texas la
mayor potencia petrolera de los eeuu
cuatro de cada diez barriles de petróleo
que se producen en los eeuu tienen su
origen en este estado
[Música]
de hecho si tejas fuera un país sería ni
más ni menos que el cuarto mayor
productor de petróleo de todo el mundo
tan sólo por detrás de arabia saudita
rusia y el resto de los eeuu
pues bien el caso es que durante años
tejas ha sido uno de los grandes motores
de la economía de los eeuu y no sólo por
el petróleo pero eso ahora puede estar
en riesgo atentos
[Música]
el milagro de texas
puede que si piensas en este lugar lo
primero que se te venga a la cabeza sean
imágenes de cowboys rodeos o barbacoas
infinitas acompañadas de chili muchísimo
chili pero lo cierto es que este estado
es mucho más con 29 millones de
habitantes tejas es el segundo estado
más poblado de los eeuu y durante al
menos las dos últimas décadas su
economía ha sido una de las locomotoras
de la economía norteamericana
hablamos de una economía del estado de
la estrella solitaria que crece de media
más que la economía nacional y que lleva
al menos tres décadas creando más
empleos que el resto del país
[Música]
tan solo desde el año 2009 en este
estado se han creado casi 3 millones de
nuevos empleos y su población su
población ha crecido más de un 14% lo
que supone más del doble que la media
nacional
durante mucho tiempo tejas ha sido algo
así como la tierra de las segundas
oportunidades el lugar al que podías
desplazarte en busca de un trabajo o una
vivienda más económica y un mejor nivel
de vida
queréis un ejemplo pues fijaos aunque
sus salarios nominales la nómina que
reciben sus trabajadores no son los más
altos del país si tenemos en cuenta los
impuestos y la capacidad de compra de
cada dólar entonces los tejanos son los
norteamericanos con salarios reales más
altos es decir con mayor poder
adquisitivo es lo que se ha venido a
conocer como el milagro tejano
[Música]
el estado de texas es responsable de
aproximadamente cuatro de cada diez
barriles de petróleo que extraen en los
eeuu y del 30% de toda la producción
petroquímica pero no se trata sólo del
oro negro la economía texana está mucho
más diversificada de lo que se piensa a
primera vista el transporte las
manufacturas la tecnología e incluso la
atención médica también son muy
importantes
de hecho el complejo médico más grande
del mundo se encuentra precisamente en
este estado es el texas medical center
de houston
y de hecho aunque pueda sorprender t una
de las industrias que más ha crecido
durante los últimos años han sido las
energías renovables tejas es ya el mayor
productor de energía eólica de todos los
estados unidos- y muy pronto se
convertirá en el segundo estado con
mayor capacidad de energía solar tan
sólo por detrás de california está
previsto que en 2020 una cuarta parte de
toda la inversión en energía solar de
los eeuu se lleva a cabo precisamente en
este estado
sin embargo amigos toda esta prosperidad
podría terminarse este 2020 al menos
durante un buen tiempo atentos
[Música]
este es el récord de récords el action
to station excepto de probar distintos
servicios en salud en su conjunto de
hueso historia
tormenta
en estos momentos texas está enfrentando
a un enorme ciclón económico
por un lado desde el punto de vista
sanitario el sars coronavirus 2 está
afectando a este estado de la misma
forma que a muchos de los países
occidentales en el momento de preparar
este vídeo en texas se han registrado
más de 14.000 casos de kobe 19 una
situación que ha llevado al gobernador
de este estado greg abbott a decretar el
distanciamiento social y el cierre de
colegios restaurantes hoteles y buena
parte de la actividad económica del
estado vamos lo que viene siendo
habitual sin embargo en el caso de texas
el impacto ha sido un poco más duro que
en otros lugares de eeuu el estado de
las estrellas solitarias la sede de
compañías aéreas tan importantes como
southwest airlines y american airlines
que por supuesto están sufriendo mucho
esta crisis
[Música]
y por otro lado está el golpe que está
suponiendo el colapso del mercado del
petróleo del que ya os hemos hablado al
comienzo de este vídeo
porque aunque la economía tejana esté
mucho más diversificada de lo que era
habitual es innegable que desde que en
el año 1901 se descubrió petróleo en una
zona situada al este de houston la
evolución del mercado del petróleo y de
la economía texana han estado
irremediablemente unidas y claro el
colapso en el precio por la caída de la
demanda que está provocando el
coronavirus ha hecho que muchas empresas
estén cerrando hasta el momento más de
50 empresas han anunciado que van a
suspender operaciones y proyectos de
inversión en el estado tejano por valor
de miles y miles de millones de dólares
y no sólo eso a día de hoy al menos 35
compañías del sector en texas están al
borde de la quiebra y más de 130
plataformas de extracción ya han cerrado
por supuesto todo esto supone también
miles y miles de despidos más tejanos
solicitaron desempleo en las últimas
cuatro semanas en todo 2019 para que os
hagáis una idea estamos hablando de casi
800 mil personas que ya han pedido el
subsidio de desempleo tan solo en las
últimas tres semanas de marzo y la
primera semana de abril y es solo el
principio se espera que el desempleo
supere el máximo histórico del estado en
esta crisis
y luego algo parecido va a ocurrir
también con la recaudación pública
evidentemente buena parte de los
ingresos derivados del petróleo se van a
evaporar
en cualquier caso amigos la buena
noticia es que con el acuerdo de la opep
plus el peor escenario parece haberse
evitado pero aún así ya texas a la
próspera texas parece que le esperan
unos meses muy pero que muy complicados
logrará texas recuperarse de este golpe
hasta donde pensáis que llegará el
impacto de esta crisis doble estaremos
acaso presenciando el fin de la que
hasta ahora ha sido una de las
locomotoras de la economía de los eeuu
que políticas penséis que debería el
estado de texas poner sobre la mesa
amigos dejadnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo se
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]